que lo que ellas prefieren hoy es una inyección.
Se la ponen en el brazo y van unas cuatro veces al año,
con una frecuencia de tres meses a por su inyección.
La razón para que a las mujeres en África les gusta tanto es
porque lo pueden esconder de sus maridos,
quienes a veces desean muchos niños.
El problema es que muchas veces cuando una mujer va a una clínica en Senegal,
la inyección está agotada.
Las clínicas están desabastecidas 150 días al año.
Así que imaginen la situación,
ella va hasta allí para obtener su inyección.
Ella sale de su campo, a veces dejando solos a sus hijos,
y no hay inyecciones.
Y ella no sabe cuándo habrá de nuevo.
Es la misma historia en la actualidad en todo el continente de África.
Y así hemos creado un mundo en crisis de vida o muerte.
Hay 100 000 mujeres al año que dicen que no quieren estar embarazadas
y mueren en el parto, 100 000 mujeres al año.
Hay otras 600 000 mujeres al año
que dicen que no querían estar embarazadas en primer lugar,
y dan a luz a un bebé
y su bebé muere en el primer mes de vida.
Sé que todo el mundo quiere salvar a estas madres y a estos niños.
Pero a lo largo del camino, nos confundimos
con nuestro propio debate.
Y ya no tratamos de salvar estas vidas.
Así que si vamos a avanzar en este tema,
tenemos que ser muy claros sobre qué es nuestra agenda.
No estamos hablando sobre el aborto.
No estamos hablando sobre el control de la población.
Hablo de dar a las mujeres el poder para salvar sus vidas,
para salvar la vida de sus hijos
y para dar a sus familias el mejor futuro posible.
Ahora, en el mundo, hay muchas cosas
que debemos hacer en la comunidad global de la salud
si queremos que el mundo sea mejor en el futuro,
cosas como combatir enfermedades.
Muchos niños mueren hoy de diarrea y de neumonía, como Uds. escucharon antes,
Esas matan literalmente a millones de niños al año.
También hay que ayudar a los pequeños agricultores,
a los campesinos que aran pequeñas parcelas de tierra en África,
a fin de poder cultivar suficiente alimento
para alimentar a sus hijos.
Y debemos asegurarnos de que
los niños reciban educación en todo el mundo.
Pero una de las cosas más simples y transformadoras que podemos hacer
es dar acceso a todos los métodos anticonceptivos
a los que casi todos los alemanes y estadounidenses
acceden en algún momento,
ellos los usan durante su vida.
Y creo que cuando tengamos muy claro qué está en nuestra agenda,
habrá un movimiento mundial a punto de ocurrir
y listo para llegar a esta idea totalmente indiscutible.
Crecí, me crié en un hogar católico.
Todavía me considero una católica practicante.
El tío abuelo de mi madre era un sacerdote jesuita.
Mi tía abuela era una monja dominicana.
Ella fue maestra y directora de escuela toda su vida.
De hecho, ella fue la que me enseñó de niña a leer.
Yo estaba muy próxima a ella.
Y fui a la escuela católica toda mi infancia
hasta irme de casa para ir a la universidad.
En mi escuela secundaria, la academia ursulina,
las monjas hicieron del servicio y la justicia social
una prioridad en la escuela.
Hoy en día, en el trabajo de la Fundación Gates,
creo aplicar las lecciones aprendidas en la escuela secundaria.
Así, en la tradición de estudiosos católicos,
las monjas también nos enseñaron a cuestionar las enseñanzas recibidas.
Y una de las enseñanzas que las niñas y mis compañeras cuestionaron
era si el control de la natalidad realmente era pecado.
Creo que una de las razones
para tener esta enorme molestia de hablar sobre la anticoncepción
es esta preocupación persistente de que
si separamos el sexo de la reproducción, fomentaremos la promiscuidad.
Y creo que es una pregunta razonable que se plantea con la anticoncepción,
¿cuál es su impacto en la moral sexual?
Pero, como la mayoría de las mujeres,
mi decisión para controlar la natalidad no tenía que ver con la promiscuidad.
Yo tenía un plan para mi futuro. Yo quería ir a la universidad.
Yo estudié mucho en la universidad,
y estaba orgullosa de ser una de las pocas mujeres graduadas
en ciencias informáticas en mi universidad.
Quería hacer carrera, por eso fui a la escuela de negocios
y me convertí en una de las ejecutivas más jóvenes de Microsoft.
Todavía recuerdo, sin embargo, cuando me fui de casa de mis padres
para para comenzar este nuevo trabajo en Microsoft.
Habían sacrificado mucho para darme 5 años de estudios superiores.
Sin embargo, al irme de casa
bajando los escalones de la entrada de la casa,
dijeron:
"A pesar de que has tenido esta gran educación,
si decides casarte y tener hijos de inmediato,
eso también nos parece bien a nosotros".
Ellos querían para mí lo que me hiciera más feliz.
Yo era libre de decidir lo que quería hacer.
Fue una sensación increíble.
De hecho, yo quería tener hijos,
pero yo deseaba tenerlos, cuando estuviera preparada.
Y por ahora, Bill y yo tenemos tres.
Y cuando nació nuestra hija mayor,
no estábamos muy seguros de cómo ser buenos padres.
Tal vez algunos conocen esa sensación.
Así que esperamos algo de tiempo antes de tener el segundo hijo.
Y no es casualidad que tengamos tres hijos
en intervalos de tres años de diferencia.
Ahora, como madre, ¿qué es lo que más deseo para mis hijos?
Quiero que se sientan como yo me sentí,
que ellos puedan hacer lo que quieran hacer en la vida.
Y así, de lo que me he dado cuenta
viajando la última década por todo el mundo para la fundación
es que todas las mujeres quieren lo mismo.
El año pasado estaba en Nairobi en uno de los barrios pobres llamado Korogocho
que literalmente significa "hombro con hombro en pie".
Y hablé con un grupo de mujeres representado aquí.
Y las mujeres hablaron abiertamente de su vida familiar
de cómo era en los barrios pobres.
Y hablaron íntimamente de
cómo hacían para controlar la natalidad.
Marianne, en el centro de la pantalla con el suéter rojo,
resumió toda ese debate de dos horas
en una frase que nunca olvidaré.
Ella dijo: "Quiero dar todo lo bueno a este niño
antes de tener otro".
Y pensé: Así es, eso es todo.
Eso es universal.
Todos queremos dar todo lo bueno para nuestros hijos.
Lo que no es universal es nuestra capacidad de proporcionar todo lo bueno.
Porque muchas mujeres sufren de violencia doméstica.
Y ni siquiera pueden abordar el tema del control de la natalidad,
incluso en su propio matrimonio.
Hay muchas mujeres que carecen de educación básica.
Incluso muchas mujeres con conocimiento y con poder
no tienen acceso a los anticonceptivos.
Durante 250 años, padres de todo el mundo
han decidido tener familias más pequeñas.
Esta tendencia ha sido constante durante un cuarto de milenio,
en todas las culturas y en todas las geografías,
con la clara excepción del África subsahariana y Asia meridional.
El francés comenzó a reducir el número de hijos a mediados de la década de 1700.
Y en los siguientes 150 años, esta tendencia se extendió por toda Europa.
Lo sorprendente para mí, al enterarme de esta historia,
es que se extendió no por capas socioeconómicas, sino por culturas.
Las personas con el mismo idioma hacen el cambio como grupo.
Ellos hicieron la misma elección para su familia,
ya bien fueran ricos o pobres.
La razón para extenderse la tendencia hacia familias más pequeñas
fue impulsada por una idea,
la idea de que las parejas pueden ejercer un control consciente
sobre el número de hijos que tienen.
Esta es una idea muy poderosa.
Esto significa que los padres tienen la capacidad de influir el futuro,
no solo aceptarlo tal y como es.
En Francia, el tamaño medio de la familia se redujo por cada década
durante 150 años consecutivamente hasta que se estabilizó.
Nos llevó mucho tiempo porque los anticonceptivos no eran tan buenos.
En Alemania, esta transición se inició en la década de 1880, y tomó solo 50 años
hasta que el tamaño de la familia se estabilizó en este país.
Y en Asia y América Latina, la transición se inició en la década de 1960,
y sucedió mucho más rápido debido a la anticoncepción moderna.
A medida que avanzamos en esta historia, es importante hacer un inciso
y recordar por qué esto se ha convertido en un tema tan polémico.
Esto se debe a que algunos programas de planificación familiar
ha recurrido a incentivos desafortunados y a políticas coercitivas.
Por ejemplo, en la década de 1960,
la India adoptó metas numéricas muy específicas
y pagaron a las mujeres que aceptaban colocarse un DIU.
Las mujeres indias eran muy listas en esa situación.
Cuando les ponían un DIU, les pagaban seis rupias.
Y entonces ¿qué hacían?
Esperaban unas horas o unos días,
y se iban a otra persona que les extraía el DIU por una rupia.
Durante décadas en EE.UU.
las mujeres afroamericanas fueron esterilizadas sin su consentimiento.
El procedimiento era tan común
que se popularizó como la apendicetomía del Mississippi.
Un capítulo trágico en la historia de mi país.
Y recientemente, en la década de 1990, en Perú,
las mujeres de los Andes recibieron anestesia
para ser esterilizadas sin su conocimiento.
Lo más sorprendente de esto
es que estas políticas coercitivas ni siquiera se necesitan.
Se llevaron a cabo en lugares
donde los padres ya querían reducir el tamaño de la familia.
Porque en toda región, una vez, tras otra,
los padres han querido tener familias más pequeñas.
No hay razón para creer
que las mujeres africanas tienen innatamente diferentes deseos.
Si tienen la opción, tendrán menos hijos.
La pregunta es:
¿invertiremos en ayudar a todas las mujeres a conseguir lo que quieren ahora?
O ¿las condenaremos a una lucha centenaria,
como si esto fuera todavía la Francia revolucionaria
y el mejor método fuera el coitus interruptus?
Empoderar a los padres, no necesita justificación.
Pero aquí está el punto, nuestro deseo de darles lo mejor a nuestros hijos
es una fuerza para el bien en el mundo.
Es lo que impulsa a las sociedades hacia adelante.
En ese mismo barrio pobre de Nairobi, conocí a una joven empresaria,
ella hacía mochilas fuera de su casa.
Ella y sus hijos pequeños iban a la fábrica local de jeans
para recoger trozos de tela vaquera.
Ella hacía estas mochilas y las vendía.
Y cuando hablé con ella, ella tenía tres hijos,
y le pregunté por su familia,
ella dijo que ella y su esposo decidieron
que no querían tener más hijos tras su tercero.
Y así, al preguntarle por qué, ella simplemente dijo:
"Bueno, porque no podría llevar mi negocio si tuviera otro hijo".
Y ella explicó los ingresos que tenía llevando su negocio
le posibilitaba poder dar una educación a sus tres hijos.
Ella era increíblemente optimista sobre el futuro de su familia.
Este es el mismo cálculo mental,
que cientos de millones de hombres y mujeres han hecho.
Y la evidencia demuestra que tienen toda la razón.
Ellos son capaces de dar a sus hijos más oportunidades
mediante la aplicación del control de la natalidad.
En Bangladesh,
hay un distrito llamado Matlab donde
investigadores han recogido datos de más de 180 000 habitantes desde 1963.
En la comunidad sanitaria mundial,
nos gusta decir que es una de las piezas más extensas de investigación realizadas.
Tenemos muchas estadísticas de salud de gran tamaño.
En uno de los estudios, ¿qué hicieron?
Eligieron a la mitad de los habitantes del pueblo para obtener anticonceptivos.
Obtuvieron formación y acceso a los anticonceptivos.
Veinte años más tarde, con base en esos pueblos,
hemos aprendido que tenían mayor calidad de vida que sus vecinos.
Las familias eran más saludables.
Las mujeres tenían menos probabilidad de morir en el parto.
Sus hijos tenían menos probabilidad de morir en los primeros 30 días de vida.
Los niños estaban mejor alimentados.
Las familias también eran más ricas.
Los salarios de las mujeres adultas eran superiores.
Los hogares tenían más activos, como ganado, tierra o ahorros.
Por último, sus hijos e hijas tenían más tiempo de escolaridad.
Así que cuando se multiplican estos efectos en millones de familias,
el producto puede ser un desarrollo económico a gran escala.
La gente habla sobre el milagro económico asiático de los años 1980,
pero no fue realmente un milagro.
Una de las principales causas del crecimiento económico en toda la región
fue esta tendencia cultural hacia familias más pequeñas.
Los cambios radicales comienzan a nivel individual de la familia,
la familia toma una decisión de lo que es mejor para sus hijos.
Cuando hacen ese cambio y toman esa decisión,
la convierten en tendencia arrasadora nacional y regional.
Si a las familias de África subsahariana se les da la oportunidad
de tomar esas decisiones de forma autónoma,
creo que ayudará a despertar un círculo virtuoso de desarrollo
en las comunidades de todo el continente.
Podemos ayudar a las familias pobres a construir un futuro mejor.
Podemos insistir en que todas las personas tienen la oportunidad
para aprender sobre anticonceptivos
y tener acceso a toda la variedad de métodos.
Creo que el objetivo es muy claro:
acceso universal a métodos anticonceptivos que las mujeres deseen.
Y para que eso suceda, significa que tanto los gobiernos ricos y pobres
deben hacer que la anticoncepción sea una prioridad absoluta.
Podemos hacer nuestra parte, en esta sala y en el mundo,
al hablar de los cientos de millones de familias
que no tienen acceso a la anticoncepción hoy
y lo que podría hacer para cambiar sus vidas si tuvieran acceso.
Creo que si Marianne y los miembros de su grupo de mujeres
pueden hablar de esto abiertamente
y tener esta discusión entre ellas y en público,
nosotros podemos, también.
Y tenemos que empezar ahora.
Porque al igual que Marianne, todos queremos
todo lo mejor para nuestros hijos.
¿Y dónde está lo polémico en eso?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: Gracias.
Tengo algunas preguntas para Melinda.
Gracias por tu valentía y por todo lo demás.
Melinda, en los últimos años
he oído a mucha gente inteligente decir cosas como:
"Ya no necesitamos preocuparnos por la cuestión de la población.
El tamaño de las familias se ha reducido de forma natural en todo el mundo.
Alcanzaremos su punto máximo en los 9000 o 10 000 millones. Y ya está".
¿Están equivocados?
Melinda Gates: Si nos fijamos en las estadísticas de toda África,
están equivocadas.
Y creo que debemos verlo, desde una perspectiva diferente.
Tenemos que verlo desde abajo hacia arriba.
Esa es una de las razones que nos generaron tantos problemas
en este tema de la anticoncepción.
Lo mirábamos de arriba a abajo
y quisimos tener números diferentes de la población con el tiempo.
Sí, nos preocupamos por el planeta. Sí, debemos tomar las decisiones correctas.
Pero las decisiones deben tomarse a nivel familiar.
Y se hace solo dando acceso a la gente y dejar que ellos elijan qué hacer
para conseguir esos cambios radicales que hemos visto en todo el mundo
a excepción de África subsahariana y en sitios del sur de Asia y Afganistán.
CA: Algunas personas de la derecha en EE.UU.
y en muchas culturas conservadoras de todo el mundo
podrían decir algo como:
"Todo muy bien al hablar de salvar vidas, empoderar a las mujeres, etc.
Pero, el sexo es sagrado.
Lo que estamos proponiendo aumentará la probabilidad
de que ocurra mucho sexo fuera del matrimonio.
Y eso está mal".
¿Qué les dirías a ellos?
MG: Yo diría que el sexo es absolutamente sagrado.
Y es sagrada en Alemania, y es sagrado en EE.UU.
y en Francia y en muchos lugares en todo el mundo.
Y el hecho de que el 98 % de las mujeres en mi país que tienen experiencia sexual
dicen que usan métodos anticonceptivos no hace al sexo menos sagrado.
Solo significa que logran tomar decisiones sobre sus vidas.
Y creo que en esa elección,
también honramos lo sacrosanto de la familia
y el carácter sagrado de la vida de la madre
y de las vidas de los niños al salvar sus vidas.
Para mí, eso es muy sagrado, también.
CA: Entonces, ¿qué hace tu fundación para promover este tema?
¿Y qué podría hacer la gente aquí y la gente que nos escucha en la web?
¿qué te gustaría que hicieran?
MG: Yo diría esto, que se unan al debate.
Hemos apuntado el sitio web. Súmense al debate.
Cuenten su historia de cómo la anticoncepción ha cambiado su vida
o la vida de alguien que conocen.
Y digan que están a favor.
Necesitamos una oleada de gente que diga: "Esto tiene sentido.
Tenemos que dar a todas las mujeres acceso, sin importar donde vivan".
Y una de las cosas que haremos
es hacer un gran evento el 11 de julio en Londres,
con una serie de países africanos,
para decir que incluimos esto en la agenda de la salud mundial.
Dedicaremos recursos a esto,
y haremos una planificación de abajo hacia arriba con los gobiernos
para asegurarnos de que las mujeres obtienen formación,
y si desean los métodos, que los obtengan.
y que tienen muchas opciones disponibles
ya sea a través de su trabajador de salud local,
o de su clínica rural de la comunidad local.
CA: Melinda, supongo que algunas de esas monjas que te enseñaron en la escuela
van a ver esta charla TED en algún momento.
¿Van a estar horrorizadas o encantadas?
MG: Yo sé que van a ver la charla TED
porque saben lo que hago y planeamos enviársela.
Las monjas que me enseñaron eran increíblemente progresistas.
Espero que estén muy orgullosas de mí
por vivir lo que nos enseñaron sobre la justicia social y el servicio.
He llegado a apasionarme por este tema
por lo que he visto en el mundo en desarrollo.
Y para mí, este tema se ha vuelto muy cercano a mi corazón
porque cumplo con estas mujeres, que tan a menudo no tienen voz.
Y no debería ser así.
Deben tener voz, deben tener acceso.
Así que espero que sientan
que estoy viviendo lo que he aprendido de ellas
en las décadas de trabajo que ya he hecho en la fundación.
CA: Tú y tu equipo trajeron a un grupo increíble de oradores hoy
al que todos estamos agradecidos.
¿Has aprendido algo?
(Risas)
MG: Dios mío, he aprendido muchas cosas. Tengo muchas preguntas complementarias.
Y creo que mucha de esta obra es un viaje.
Ya has oído la discusión sobre el viaje a través de la energía,
o el viaje a través del diseño social,
o el viaje por venir que diga:
"¿Por qué no hay ninguna mujer en esta plataforma?"
Y creo que para todos los que trabajamos en estos temas de desarrollo,
aprendemos hablando con otras personas.
Se aprende con la práctica, probando y cometiendo errores.
Y con las preguntas que una se hace.
A veces es la pregunta lo que ayuda a guiar la respuesta,
la siguiente persona puede ayudarte a responderla.
Así que tengo muchas preguntas para los oradores de hoy.
Y pienso que fue un día increíble.
CA: Melinda, gracias por invitarnos a todos en este viaje contigo.
Muchas gracias. MG: Gracias, Chris.